Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Woman: AAH!
Woman #2: AAH!
Tyra: SEMI-FINALISTS
FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FLEW TO LOS ANGELES
TO PURSUE THEIR DREAM.
YOU GUYS READY TO BE STARS?
Women: YEAH!
Tyra: THEY WERE
PUT TO THE TEST
IN GRUELING INTERVIEWS.
SO WHY ARE YOU HERE?
Magdalena: LATINAS
HAVEN'T BEEN REPRESENTED.
Tyra: WE MET MAGDALENA,
WHO PUT HER NURSING CAREER
ON HOLD TO FOLLOW HER HEART...
Kelle: THEY USED TO SAY,
"KELLE IS JUST A WHITE GIRL
WITH A REALLY GOOD TAN."
Tyra: KELLE,
A WEALTHY GALLERY OWNER
FROM NEW YORK CITY...
Ann: I'M NOT GONNA LET
ANYONE STOP ME.
Tyra: ANN, A TOUGH JOCK
FROM ERIE, PENNSYLVANIA...
Amanda: I'M LEGALLY BLIND.
Women: (gasp)
Tyra: AND AMANDA,
WHO REVEALED
HER TRAGIC SECRET.
Eva: I TOLD YOU! I TOLD YOU!
Tyra: BUT ONLY 14 GIRLS
MADE THE FINAL CUT,
AND TONIGHT
THEIR JOURNEY BEGINS.
♪♪♪
Ann: WHOO! WHERE ARE WE?
I'VE NEVER BEEN HERE.
Eva: TIMES SQUARE!
LANDING IN NEW YORK
AND LOOKING OUT OF THE WINDOW,
I'M JUST SO OVERWHELMED
WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON.
Ann: WAIT, I WANNA BE
IN THIS SEAT.
I CAN'T SEE.
I CAME INTO THIS
BEING CONFIDENT, AND I THINK
THAT A LOT OF THE GIRLS
ARE INTIMIDATED BY ME.
I WANT THEM TO BE.
HEY, BABY!
Norelle: ANN--SHE'S GONNA BE
IN THIS COMPETITION
FOR A LONG TIME.
SHE'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
HER FACE AND, LIKE, HER BODY,
LIKE, SHE LOOKS AMAZING.
Jennipher: WHOO!
OH, MY GOD!
Yaya: YAY!
Leah: GIRLS--YOU KNOW,
WE JUST REALLY MET EACH OTHER.
I MEAN, SO WE'RE
COMING INTO THIS REALLY NEW
ABOUT EVERYONE'S LOOK.
I KNOW I CAN LOOK
VERY PLAIN JANE.
MY JOB IS TO PROVE TO TYRA
THAT I WANT THIS
AND THAT I CAN DO IT.
Jennipher: IT'S SO EXCITING!
Kelle: YOU GUYS CAN SEE
MY BACKYARD.
I LOVE IT.
Jennipher: MY BACKYARD.
Kelle: I GREW UP
IN A PLACE CALLED SEAGATE,
WHICH IS, LIKE, THE LAST
GATED COMMUNITY IN NEW YORK.
AND THEN I MOVED TO MANHATTAN,
AND I'VE JUST BEEN A CITY GIRL
EVER SINCE.
AROUND THAT CORNER LIES
ALL THE EXCITEMENT OF NEW YORK!
LOOK AT IT!
I KNOW I CAN COME OFF
A LITTLE STRONG.
LIKE, PEOPLE ALWAYS SAY, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, THAT YOU HAVE
A PRESENCE ABOUT YOU.
NOW I JUST WANNA MAKE IT
LIKE AN EASY PRESENCE.
TIMES SQUARE! WE ARE HERE!
Magdalena: I'M SO HAPPY
RIGHT NOW!
WE'RE TAKEN TO SOMEPLACE
IN TIMES SQUARE.
WE'RE THINKING, "THIS IS
THE HOUSE, THIS IS THE HOUSE."
♪♪♪
Magdalena: WE GET UP
TO THE ROOF,
AND THERE IS TYRA,
WAITING FOR US.
AND WE'RE LIKE, "OH, MY GOD!
THERE SHE IS."
Tyra: HEY, YOU GUYS!
Women: HEY, TYRA!
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU GUYS ARE MY PERSONAL
FINAL 14.
Women: (screaming)
Tyra: LOOK AT
THOSE BILLBOARDS.
ONE OF THOSE MIGHT BE YOU
REAL SOON!
RIGHT?
YOU GUYS, THIS IS NEW YORK CITY.
THIS IS THE CITY THAT
NEVER, EVER WHAT?
Women: SLEEPS!
Tyra: SLEEPS!
Kristi: WE KNOW.
Tyra: IT'S TRUE.
SPEAKIN' OF NEVER SLEEPIN'...
Women: (laugh)
Tyra: YOU GUYS ARE NOT GONNA
BE GETTIN' ANY SLEEP TONIGHT.
Woman: OH, MY GOD.
Tyra: A MODEL NEVER KNOWS
WHERE HER NEXT JOB
IS COMIN' FROM.
THAT PHONE
IS CONSTANTLY RINGING,
AND YOU NEVER KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE GONNA GO.
ALL RIGHT?
SO YOUR FIRST ASSIGNMENT IS
A SEXY, FREAKY-DEAKY
BIKINI SHOOT.
Kelle: WHOO!
Ann: YEAH, YEAH.
Tyra: BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
DOIN' YOUR SHOOT HERE, MNH-MNH.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE DOIN'
YOUR VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT...
IN JAMAICA!
Women: (screaming)
Cassie: AAH!
WE'RE GOIN' TO JAMAICA.
THIS IS THE ONLY TIME
I'D EVER HAVE A CHANCE
TO DO THIS.
Tyra: THE PLANE IS LEAVING
IN A COUPLE OF HOURS, OKAY?
YOU GUYS, THIS IS
THE REAL THING, OKAY?
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
YOU ARE STANDING NEXT TO
YOUR COMPETITOR.
GOOD LUCK, YOU GUYS.
Ann: THANK YOU.
Tyra: AND MAKE ME PROUD,
AND WORK IT OUT.
Women: (screaming)
Tyra: GOOD-BYE.
♪♪♪
Kelle: ♪ WE'RE IN JAMAICA ♪
♪ WE JUST FOUND OUT TONIGHT... ♪
I'M REALLY EXCITED.
Leah: I KNOW.
Kelle: I'M LIKE
AN OUTGOING PERSON,
BUT I'VE NEVER REALLY FIT
INTO THE GROUP.
PEOPLE USED TO SAY, LIKE,
"OH, KELLE, YOU'RE JUST LIKE
A WHITE GIRL
WITH A REALLY GOOD TAN,"
OR THINK THAT I'M, LIKE,
REALLY STUCK UP.
BUT THINGS ARE GOING WONDERFUL
RIGHT NOW.
I FEEL REALLY FRIENDLY
WITH ALL THE GIRLS.
♪ BUM, BUM, SHH ♪♪
Eva: KELLE--
SHE'S JUST SO WHITEWASHED,
IT'S NOT EVEN FUNNY.
(imitates Kelle)
"I'M THE ONLY BLACK PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN
MY WHITE CUL-DE-SAC."
Julie: YEAH!
I HEARD HER SAY THAT.
Eva: I WAS LIKE SHUT UP! GOD!
Eva: IT'S SO IRRITATING.
Yaya: THAT'S WHO SHE IS.
Eva: BUT--NO.
IT SHOULD NOT BE WHO SHE IS.
Yaya: UMM--IT'S HARD TO SAY
THAT SOMEBODY IS NOT BLACK.
THERE ARE A LOT OF BLACK PEOPLE
WHO GREW UP LIKE KELLE.
Eva: AND YOU'RE BLACK.
GET WITH IT, LOVE IT,
EMBRACE IT--YOU'RE BLACK.
♪♪♪
Kristi: IT IS 6 A.M.-ISH,
I THINK.
AND WE DIDN'T SLEEP LAST NIGHT.
WE'RE FLYING TO JAMAICA
FOR OUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
Eva: COMING INTO ALL OF THIS,
MY INTENTIONS WEREN'T
TO CULTIVATE ANY TYPE
OF RELATIONSHIPS,
BUT I LOVE ANN.
Ann: WHOO!
I LIKED EVA FROM THE BEGINNING.
IT'S JUST LIKE WE CLICK.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE FRIENDSHIPS
THAT ISN'T FORCED.
Woman: STRAIGHT AHEAD.
Leah: I'M THANKFUL.
THAT IT TAKES US THREE HOURS
TO GET TO JAMAICA
SO I CAN SLEEP ON THE PLANE.
Ann: I HATE FLYING.
Norelle: WHAT'S WRONG?
Ann: I HATE THIS.
I... HATE IT.
MY FRESHMAN YEAR OF COLLEGE,
I HAD A HORRIBLE FLIGHT.
I SWORE TO MYSELF
I WOULD NEVER FLY AGAIN
AFTER THAT.
Julie: ANN FREAKED OUT
ON THE PLANE.
Ann: EVA...
I NEED YOU.
Julie: I LOOK OVER,
I'M LIKE,
"EVA, SHE'S CALLING YOU."
EVA'S LIKE, "HUH?"
Julie: I'M LIKE,
"MAKE HER STOP CRYING."
Ann: MAMA, I NEED YOU.
Julie: THIS IS SUCH
A WEIRD RELATIONSHIP.
Ann: I'M SORRY.
Eva: ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE FINE, BABY. YOU'RE FINE.
I LOVE ANN. ANN IS WONDERFUL.
Ann: I DON'T WANNA BE
LIKE THIS.
Eva: ANN HAS ALL THESE
UNDER LAYERS THAT PEOPLE
WOULDN'T IMAGINE THAT SHE HAD.
Ann: I JUST WANT SOMEONE
TO... HOLD MY HAND.
Eva: I DON'T THINK SHE
BELIEVES THAT SHE IS AS STRONG
AS SHE REALLY IS.
IT'S OKAY.
Ann: EVA HELPED ME
THROUGH IT.
SHE WAS, YOU KNOW, CALMING ME.
AND THEN I FELL ASLEEP,
AND THEN I WAS FINE.
♪♪♪
Kelle: WE FINALLY LAND
IN MONTEGO BAY, JAMAICA,
AND IT'S JUST--THE SUN
IS SHINING, AND AUTOMATICALLY,
THAT JAMAICAN BREEZE HITS YOU.
♪♪♪
Magdalena: STOP PLAYING.
Kelle: LIKE THEY DO
FOR VICTORIA'S SECRET ADS.
Magdalena: STOP PLAYING.
I REALLY, REALLY
WANT TO BE A MODEL.
IT IS A RISK FOR ME.
I'M IN SCHOOL RIGHT NOW AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF MASSACHUSETTS
IN THE NURSING PROGRAM.
I HAVE A GREAT INTERNSHIP,
WHERE I WANT TO WORK
WHEN I GRADUATE.
I'M GONNA BE GIVING THAT UP
FOR THIS.
♪♪♪
Jay: LADIES!
Eva: HEY, HEY!
Jay: PERFECT.
SO, LADIES,
WE'RE HERE IN JAMAICA.
Women: (scream)
Jay: WE'RE AT THE
ROCKHOUSE HOTEL.
WE'RE SO LUCKY
TO BE SHOOTING HERE TODAY.
SO YOU MIGHT HAVE FORGOTTEN,
I'M JAY.
MR. JAY, AS TYRA CALLS ME.
THIS IS MISS J. OVER HERE
TO MY LEFT.
ALSO KNOWN AS J. ALEXANDER,
THE RUNWAY DIVA.
Eva: HEY!
Jay: SO YOUR FASHION SHOOT
IS GONNA BE KIND OF LIKE
EDGY SWIMWEAR.
NICK CARDILLICCHIO
IS YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY.
Nick: HELLO, GIRLS.
Toccara: HI.
Jay: NOW FOR ALL
YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS,
WE HAVE THE TOP GLAM SQUAD--
THE BEST
IN EACH OF THEIR FIELDS.
WE GOT MATHU OVER THERE,
AN AMAZING MAKE-UP ARTIST.
AND THIS IS MICHELLE.
SHE IS YOUR WARDROBE STYLIST.
SHE'S GONNA MAKE SURE
YOU ALL LOOK FIERCE.
WE'VE GOT THE FAMOUS DANILO,
A HAIR MAGICIAN.
I KNOW YOU'RE TIRED,
I KNOW IT'S ROUGH.
BUT I NEED YOU GUYS
TO TURN IT OUT.
J. ALEXANDER, MYSELF,
NICK AND TYRA
ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO JUDGE
THE 14 OF YOU
TO SEE WHO DOES THE BEST
AND WHO DOES THE WORST.
AND I WANT YOU GUYS
TO UNDERSTAND,
THE HOUSE IN NEW YORK
CAN ONLY HOLD 13 OF YOU.
Women: (groan)
Jay: ONE OF YOU--
AT THE END OF THIS PHOTO SHOOT--
WILL BE PACKING YOUR BAGS
AND GOING HOME
AND NOT MOVING INTO THE HOUSE
IN NEW YORK.
♪♪♪
Jay: ONE OF YOU--
AT THE END OF THIS PHOTO SHOOT--
WILL BE PACKING YOUR BAGS
AND GOING HOME.
Magdalena: IN JAMAICA,
JAY MANUEL TELLS US
AFTER THIS PHOTO SHOOT,
SOMEBODY WILL BE ELIMINATED.
Jay: THE REMAINING GIRLS
WILL RETURN TO NEW YORK
AND THE JUDGES THERE
WILL MAKE A SECOND ELIMINATION
BASED ON THE PHOTOS TAKEN HERE.
Toccara: SO IT'S, LIKE,
OKAY, TIME TO WORK.
♪♪♪
Magdalena: I'M LOOKIN'
AT ALL THESE GIRLS, I'M LIKE,
DAMN, ALL OF 'EM PRETTY,
ALL OF 'EM HAVE, LIKE,
POPPING PERSONALITIES,
AND MY COMPETITION IS TOUGH.
Ann: I DID HAVE
A NERVOUS BREAKDOWN
ON THE WAY TO JAMAICA.
I'M DEAD TIRED.
LIKE, MY ENERGY LEVEL
NEEDS TO BE UP.
♪♪♪
Jay: SO ARE YOU READY?
Eva: MM-HMM.
Jay: EVA,
THIS IS NOT A PINUP.
THIS IS NOT A CHEESY,
YOU KNOW, BATHING SUIT MAGAZINE.
FASHION. THERE YOU GO.
Nick: OKAY, YOU GOT IT.
HERE WE GO, CASSIE.
Jay: THINK OF YOURSELF
AS A HIGHFASHION MODEL.
Nick: THERE IT IS.
Jay: I WANT TO TRY SOMETHING
A LITTLE MORE ANIMALISTIC,
A BIT SAVAGE OR SOMETHING.
THINK OF AN ANIMAL.
Cassie: THIS IS WHAT
I THINK OF WHEN I THINK
OF AN ANIMAL.
Jay: YOU THINK ANIMALS DO THIS?
OOH!
Nick: ALL RIGHT, CASSIE,
WE GOT IT.
Jay: GREAT. NEXT.
Nick: THE FINGERS
ON YOUR LEFT HAND...
Jay: KRISTI,
THINK "LONG NECK."
Nick: GO AHEAD.
(camera shutter clicks)
J.: LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE
GAS, BABY,
LIKE YOU GOTTA FART.
Nick: WE GOT IT.
Jay: AMANDA,
UNLEASH THAT CRAZY SIDE.
Nick: GREAT.
J.: THE BROKEN-DOWN
DOLL LOOK.
I LOVE
THE BROKEN-DOWN DOLL LOOK.
Nick: WE GOT IT.
ALL RIGHT, KELLE.
Jay: WORK. THERE SHE GOES.
Nick: RIGHT IN HERE. NICE.
Jay: I LOVE WHERE IT'S GOIN',
BUT IT'S LOOKING
A LITTLE HOOTCHIE.
Kelle: JAY IS SAYING, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, "STOP LOOKING
SO HOOTCHIE MAMA,
START LOOKING MORE COUTURE."
AND I'M LIKE, "OH, MY GOD!
OKAY, UM... "
(camera shutter clicks)
Nick: WE GOT IT. WE GOT IT.
Jay: COOL.
Nick: MAGDALENA,
CAN YOU CHIN UP A LITTLE BIT?
(camera shutter clicks)
Jay: THINK OF ELONGATING
THE NECK.
(camera shutter clicks)
Jay: I LOVE
MAGDALENA'S LIMBS.
HER LEGS ARE SO LONG.
I JUST FEEL LIKE I WANT HER
TO WORK IT MORE.
Nick: RIGHT.
Jay: THINK A LITTLE
ANIMALISTIC.
Miss J.: YEAH, YEAH.
Jay: YES, THERE YOU GO.
Jay: LOSE THE QUESTION MARK
IN THE FACE FOR ME.
OH, THAT'S GREAT.
(camera shutter clicks)
Michelle: I LIKE IT.
WE'LL LEAVE IT.
Leah: THE COMPETITION'S
STARTING, AND IT'S HARD
BECAUSE I SEE OTHER GIRLS,
AND THEN YOU START COMPARING--
LIKE THEY HAVE MORE FASHION
KNOWLEDGE THAN I DO,
AND YOU HAVE TO REALLY BE
SECURE WITH YOURSELF.
Nick: WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
Leah: LEAH.
Nick: NICK.
Leah: NICK.
Nick: ALL RIGHT,
WE'RE SHOOTING.
Leah: ALL RIGHT.
WHEN I GET IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA, I'M GONNA HAVE TO
LET GO OF ALL MY INHIBITIONS
AND JUST HIT IT.
Jay: YES, THAT'S PRETTY.
STRETCHING THROUGH.
IT'S GOTTA FEEL--
IT'S GOTTA BE--
IT'S VERY NATURAL.
Nick: OKAY, YOU'RE OPENING
YOUR EYES TOO WIDE.
SO WHEN YOU GET INTO IT,
BE STILL.
PICK THINGS YOU CAN HOLD STILL.
Jay: DON'T MOVE THE HEAD
TOO MUCH.
DON'T LOSE YOUR POSE TOO MUCH.
Nick: I THINK LEAH'S
A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT I THINK SHE WAS
A LITTLE BIT SELF-CONSCIOUS.
STAY THERE.
AND LEAH DOESN'T TAKE DIRECTION.
HOLD STILL.
(camera shutter clicks)
Nick: WE GOT IT.
Jay: THAT'S GORGEOUS.
J.: THE YAYA SISTERHOOD.
WOW.
Jay: YES.
SHE IS WORKING
AS IF THE RENT IS DUE...
J.: IS DUE!
Jay: TOMORROW.
J.: BABY.
Jay: YES. THERE YOU GO.
YES, LOVE THAT.
(camera shutter clicks)
J.: AFRICAN ROYALTY!
Jay: YAYA BLEW ME AWAY.
EVERY FRAME WAS AN AD CAMPAIGN.
Nick: YOUR WHOLE THING
WAS GREAT.
Jay: GREAT. EXCELLENT. NEXT.
(camera shutter clicks)
Jay: JENNIPHER,
TRY SOMETHING TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
Jennipher: WHOO!
Nick: WE GOT IT. IT'S GREAT.
Jay: LOVE IT. YES.
PINUP IS GETTING A LITTLE HOE-Y.
Nick: HOE GIRL, HOE.
TOCCARA LOOKED AMAZING
IN HER BATHING SUIT.
Toccara: WHAT? WHO?
Jay: MY CONCERN WITH TOCCARA
IS THAT SHE ALLOWS TOO MUCH
OF HER PERSONALITY
GET INTO THE WAY.
NOT BUTT UP IN THE AIR, HONEY.
J.: WHOA.
Jay: DOWN.
IT LOOKS A LITTLE BETTY BOOP,
AND IT LOOKS A LITTLE PINUPISH.
Toccara: (growls)
Jay: YES! WORKED. LOVE IT.
Nick: WE GOT IT.
Jay: LOVE IT.
OKAY, NORELLE, THAT ONE
FEELS A LITTLE LIKE
YOU'RE TAKING A DUMP.
YES!
Nick: THAT'S GOOD.
Jay: NICOLE, SHOULDER--
LIKE ROTATE THE UPPER SH--YES.
Nick: NICE.
J.: WATCH THAT RIGHT PINKIE.
Jay: GREAT.
(camera shutter clicks)
J.: PINKIE.
Nick: WE GOT IT.
HERE WE GO, JULIE.
Jay: ARMS OUT MAYBE.
(camera shutter clicks)
Jay: YES, YES. LOVE IT.
Nick: VERY GOOD.
J.: THERE YOU GO.
GIVE ME A "KAMA SUTRA" POSE.
Jay: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
THAT'S--I LOVE THAT.
J.: "KAMA SUTRA."
Nick: ALL RIGHT. HERE WE GO.
Jay: ANN, THAT'S LOOKIN'
A LITTLE PORNO.
J.: NO CRAB CLAWS.
Jay: REACH FOR THAT LIGHT
AS IF IT'S SAVING YOUR LIFE.
ANN--HUGE DISAPPOINTMENT.
ENERGY!
Nick: NOTHIN' HAPPENING.
Jay: 200%. ENERGY, LIKE...
I JUST WANNA REACH IN
AND PULL SOMETHING OUT.
ANN IS JUST RELYING
ON BEING GORGEOUS,
BUT IF I HAVE A DEAD SLAB
OF MEAT IN FRONT OF A CAMERA,
I CAN'T DO ANYTHING WITH THAT.
I NEED AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
TO WANT TO BE A TOP MODEL.
Jay: THANKS.
Kelle: YOU LOOK GOOD
OUT THERE.
Kristi: YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT THEY LIKE.
Jay: YO, YOU READY?
Women: HEY, YEAH!
Jay: SO I KNOW YOU GUYS
WANT TO GET SOME SLEEP,
SO YOU'RE GONNA GO AND CHECK IN
AT THE BEACHES NEGRIL RESORT.
NOW TOMORROW MORNING AT 10 A.M.
THERE'S GONNA BE A BRUNCH.
I'M GONNA STOP BY AT THE BRUNCH,
AND I'M GONNA DELIVER
AN ENVELOPE, OKAY?
WE ALL KNOW WHAT'S GONNA BE
IN THAT ENVELOPE?
ONE OF YOU GIRLS
HAVE TO GO HOME.
Tyra: HELLO?
Jay: HEY, TYRA.
J.: HEY.
Tyra: HI, MISS J.,
HI, MR. JAY.
HI, NICK.
Nick: HI.
Jay: SO I SENT YOU THROUGH
SOME DIGITAL PHOTOS
OF ALL THE GIRLS WE SHOT TODAY.
UH, I KNOW THIS IS DIFFICULT
AND DIFFERENT,
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE A DECISION.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANTED
TO START OFF WITH KELLE.
Tyra: WHOO! CHILD.
THIS PICTURE OF KELLE IS--
IT'S A LITTLE HOOTCHIE,
AND KELLE IS REALLY LIKE...
(imitates Kelle)
"OH, MY GOD!"
(normal voice) SO WHERE'S THIS,
LIKE, INNER HOOTCHIFIED GIRL
COMIN' OUT?
WE GOTTA BEAT IT OUT,
'CAUSE THAT IS NOT CUTE.
Jay: NEXT GIRL--OOH!
J.: OOH!
Jay: WE'RE LOOKIN'
AT MAGDALENA, TYRA.
Tyra: MAGDALENA WAS
ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
I MEAN, I LOVE HER FIRE.
Nick: WELL, I KEPT ON TRYING
WITH MAGDALENA,
AND I SORT OF FELT LIKE SHE
REALLY DID NOT HAVE ANY FIRE.
PRETTY VACANT BEHIND THE EYES.
Jay: LEAH--HER SHOTS
ARE JUST MEDIOCRE.
Tyra: THERE'S SOMETHIN'
NOT STRONG ABOUT 'EM.
Jay: TOCCARA--
SHE LOOKS GREAT.
Tyra: YOU GUYS DID YOUR THING
BY PUTTIN' HER IN THAT SWIMSUIT.
SHE LOOKS SLAMMIN'.
Jay: SO NOW WE'RE LOOKING
AT ANN, OKAY?
J.: OUCH.
Jay: THIS GIRL NEEDS
SOME ENERGY.
Nick: I THOUGHT
SHE LOOKED ELEGANT,
I THOUGHT
SHE LOOKED INTERESTING.
THE MINUTE SHE GOT IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA, SHE DISAPPEARED.
Tyra: I THINK SHE'S THINKIN',
"MY BODY'S GREAT," YOU KNOW,
"I'M A GREAT ATHLETE,
AND THAT'S GONNA MAKE ME
A GREAT MODEL."
ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS,
I GUESS WE'VE MADE A DECISION.
J.: SEE YOU SOON. BYE.
Nick: BYE.
Tyra: BYE.
♪♪♪
Ann: WHAT IS THIS, POTATO?
Kelle: YEAH.
Ann: MY PHOTO SHOOT YESTERDAY
WAS DEFINITELY CHALLENGING.
I FEEL WORRIED ABOUT GOING HOME.
Jay: WELL, I GOTTA
GIVE YOU GUYS THE REALITY
OF THE SITUATION.
ABOUT A HANDFUL OF YOU
WERE GOOD.
A HUGE GROUP OF YOU
WERE MEDIOCRE.
AND THERE WAS A HANDFUL
THAT WERE JUST BAD.
THIS ENVELOPE
HAS ONE NAME IN IT.
SO AFTER WE LEAVE,
READ THE NAME ON IT,
AND THIS GIRL HAS TO PACK
HER BAGS RIGHT NOW.
OFF TO THE AIRPORT,
AND YOU'RE GOIN' HOME.
SO I'M GONNA LEAVE IT
RIGHT HERE.
Eva: LEAH.
Jay: SEE YOU GUYS LATER.
Leah: I WANTED TO READ
THE ENVELOPE BECAUSE
IF IT WAS ME,
I WANTED TO SEE MY NAME.
I MEAN, IT WAS A LITTLE
PROTECTION FOR MYSELF, I GUESS.
Leah: "MAGDALENA."
Toccara: BYE, MAMA...
Magdalena: I JUST
GOT ELIMINATED.
THE FIRST GIRL.
Ann: TAKE CARE.
Magdalena: BYE, YOU GUYS.
JUST THE FACT THAT I DID IT,
LIKE, I'M PROUD OF MYSELF.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF MYSELF.
I'M STILL GONNA GO OUT THERE
AND DO ME
AND DO WHATEVER I HAVE TO DO
TO MAKE MYSELF HAPPY.
♪♪♪
Nicole: MAGDALENA'S GONE.
AFTER THE ELIMINATION,
WE PACKED UP AND FLEW BACK
TO NEW YORK.
Kelle: GET OFF THE PLANE,
AND TYRA HAS ARRANGED
A HUGE S.U.V. LIMO
TO PICK US UP,
WHICH IS, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE ALL "BIG PIMPIN'."
♪♪♪
Toccara: OHH! AAH!
TYRA MAIL!
Women: (scream)
Julie: SHUT UP...QUIET.
Toccara: "I'VE ARRANGED
THIS RIDE TO THE EAST SIDE,
WHERE ALL YOU ARE NOW
GOING TO RESIDE.
SO OFF YOU GO TO THE FAMED
WALDORF-ASTORIA."
Women: (screaming)
Eva: I WAS LIKE,
"YEAH, YEAH!"
I WAS SO EXCITED--
LIKE THE BEST OF THE BEST.
STAYING IN THIS HOTEL,
EVERYBODY JUST COULDN'T WAIT
TO GET TO THE HOUSE.
♪♪♪
Ann: MAMA, DO YOU WANNA
STILL ROOM TOGETHER?
Eva: DEFINITELY.
Ann: IF I WANTED TO ROOM
TOGETHER WITH EVA.
I HAD HOPED THAT WE COULD
BE FAIR ABOUT IT.
IF THERE'S A DISCREPANCY
AND WE WANT A ROOM
THAT YOU GUYS WANT,
THEN WE'LL FIGHT PAPER, SCISSORS
ROCK OR SOMETHING.
Toccara: ANN IS LIKE,
"WE'RE GONNA PLAY PAPER,
SCISSORS, ROCKS FOR A BED."
Julie: NOBODY AGREED TO IT
THOUGH, AT THAT TIME,
FOR THE, LIKE, BEDS OR ANYTHING.
♪♪♪
Kelle: WE'RE ALL WALKING
TOWARDS THE ROOM.
WE TURN THAT CORNER
AND WE SEE OUR NEW HOME.
Women: (screaming)
Julie: OH, MY GOD, THE WALL!
Toccara: OH, THERE IS FOOD.
THE HOUSE IS
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
Amanda: THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT STYLES.
THERE'S OUR MEETING ROOM
WHICH IS THE ORANGE, YOU KNOW,
LIKE, RUNWAY PRACTICE.
AND THEN YOU HAVE
THE EDITOR'S SUITE
WHICH IS JUST THIS GORGEOUS
COLLECTION OF, LIKE,
WORLDLY TRAVELS.
Eva: THEY'RE ALL HER.
OH, MY GOD,
IT WAS SO OVERWHELMING.
AND THEN YOU GO INTO
ALL THE BEDROOMS...
Kelle: THERE'S THIS ONE ROOM,
"THE STUDIO," WHICH IS VERY MUCH
LIKE, YOU KNOW, THERE'S FILM,
LIKE, CAMERAS HANGING AROUND.
Leah: IT'S GREAT! IT'S GREAT!
WE RAN THROUGH ALL THE ROOMS.
I JUST STOPPED
IN THE FITTING ROOM.
I'M LIKE, "THIS IS MY ROOM."
PINK!
I LOVE PINK!
Julie: THIS IS NOT MINE.
IT'S PINK.
I WALK INTO THE NEXT ROOM.
IT'S, YOU KNOW, COUTURE ROOM.
EVERYTHING'S, LIKE, RAW SILK.
I WAS LIKE, "I NEED THIS ROOM."
INDIAN CALL THIS BED.
Nicole: 13 OF US
IN THIS HOUSE RIGHT NOW,
AND WE'RE LOOKING, THERE'S FOUR
BEDS IN EACH ROOM, THREE ROOMS,
THAT'S 12.
WELL, I KNEW THAT THERE WAS
GONNA BE SOME PROBLEMS.
Yaya: THAT'S MY BED.
Amanda: THIS IS MINE
RIGHT HERE.
Ann: GIRLS WERE GRABBING BEDS
AND STUFF, AND I WAS WAITING
FOR EVA.
Eva: OH, MY GOD,
LOOK AT THIS BATHROOM!
Ann: I THOUGHT WE'D ROOM
TOGETHER.
Eva: LOOK WHAT I FOUND.
BUT I'M, LIKE, SO EXCITED ABOUT
THE THINGS IN THE HOUSE THAT
I DIDN'T EVEN RUN FOR A BED.
AS USUAL, I'M THE LAST ONE
TROLLEYING ALONG.
Ann: SOMEONE'S HERE,
SOMEONE'S THERE
AND SOMEONE'S THERE.
THIS IS NOT HAPPENING.
I'M ROOMING WITH YOU.
Eva: UNCOOL,
WE'RE SO ROOMING.
Ann: NO, LIKE, PUT YOUR...
WE'LL GO IN AND TALK ABOUT IT.
Eva: TALK TIME.
FAMILY ROOM TIME.
LET'S GO.
All:
FAMILY ROOM TIME.
FAMILY ROOM CHAT.
THIS IS A BED? I'M HERE.
THIS IS MY BED.
Ann: IT TURNED OUT
THERE'S A BED IN
THE EDITOR'S SUITE.
Eva: I GOT MY BED!
Julie: AS SOON AS EVA SAID,
"I'M GONNA SLEEP
IN THE FAMILY ROOM,"
ANN THREW A BIG HISSY FIT.
Ann: TWO PEOPLE WANTED
ONE ROOM.
Ann: THEN DRAW,
WHOEVER LOSES, LOSES.
Toccara: NO, I'M STAYIN' WHERE
I'M AT.
I'M STAYING IN
MY ROOM.
Ann: COULD YOU LISTEN
TO WHAT I'M SAYING?
Cassie: "I WANNA ROOM
WITH EVA." WELL, THAT'S NOT
POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW.
Ann: OKAY, BUT, YES, IT IS,
BECAUSE WE SAID, LIKE,
ARE YOU KIDDING?
Toccara: WHO AGREED?
Yaya: WHO AGREED ON IT?
Ann: OKAY, WELL, THEN,
ALL RIGHT, GREAT.
GO... YOURSELVES.
I'LL BE IN MY ROOM.
Toccara: ANN, BIG DEAL,
TOUGH TITTY.
Ann: I'VE BECOME REALLY CLOSE
TO EVA, AND I WOULD THINK THAT
IF I WAS IN HER POSITION,
I WOULD'VE BEEN, LIKE,
"NO, I'M ROOMING WITH YOU."
WELL, SHE KIND OF JUST PLAYED
PASSIVE AND SAID THAT SHE'S
GONNA LIVE IN THE LIVING ROOM.
SO NOW I'M LIVING IN
THE PINK ROOM.
Leah: THIS ROOM IS CALLED
"PINK POSITIVE," SO YOU HAVE TO
BE POSITIVE TO BE IN THE ROOM.
Eva: AS MUCH AS I LOVE ANN,
I AM GONNA BE EVA REGARDLESS.
ANN CAN BITCH AND MOAN,
BUT EVA'S GONNA REMAIN EVA.
MY ROOM IS COOL! I DON'T CARE!
LOOK AT MY STUFF.
Leah: ISN'T THAT
AN AWESOME VIEW?
Ann: OH, I HAVEN'T SEEN
THE OUTSIDE.
AFTER MOVING INTO THE HOUSE,
ME AND EVA HAVE SPLIT UP.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME RIGHT NOW
FOR ME TO HAVE A FRIENDSHIP
WITH EVA.
AND I DID ASK EVA TO TALK.
I'M HURT BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T
STICK UP FOR ME TO ROOM WITH ME.
Eva: HOW DID I NOT STICK UP?
...I'M SORRY.
Ann: BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T SAY...
NO, EVA--
Eva: IF YOU WANNA BITCH
AND MOAN ABOUT EVERYTHING, ANN,
THAT'S YOU.
THAT'S NOT MY PERSONALITY.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT'S
GONNA HAPPEN.
Ann: DID YOU NOT WANNA ROOM
WITH ME?
LIKE, IS THAT NOT
SOMETHING YOU--
Eva: FAR FROM, HUN.
Ann: OKAY, THAT'S FINE, BUT--
Eva: BUT BY THE SAME TOKEN,
ANN, AS CLOSE AS WE ARE,
WE STILL DON'T KNOW EACH OTHER,
AND THAT'S A FEAR FOR ME
BECAUSE FOR ONLY ONE PERSON
IN THIS BITCH I HAVE LET
MY GUARDS COMPLETELY DOWN.
Ann: I DON'T WANNA CHANGE
THE WAY I FEEL ABOUT ANYONE.
LIKE, I DON'T WANNA TRY
AND CONTROL THAT.
LIKE, I LOVE YOU.
LIKE, I WILL BE FRIENDS WITH YOU
FOR THE REST...
Eva: STOP, ANN.
Ann: I KNOW! NO, YOU...
YOU WILL BE IN MY WEDDING.
LIKE, I SWEAR TO GOD.
LIKE, I LOVE YOU.
AND, LIKE, IT KILLS ME TO WALK
AROUND THIS HOUSE KNOWING THAT
I CAN'T, LIKE, TALK TO YOU.
Toccara: ANN IS CODEPENDENT.
ANN NEEDS EVA TO SURVIVE.
Ann: I BELIEVE IN YOU.
LIKE, I WANT YOU TO WIN THIS
MORE THAN I THINK I WANT ME
TO WIN THIS.
Cassie: ANN DOESN'T KNOW HOW
TO BE INDEPENDENT AND CONFIDENT
ON HER OWN,
AND I THINK THAT WILL DEFINITELY
SHOW THROUGH IN PICTURES.
Tocarra: AW.
Ann: OKAY, SHUT UP.
Women: AW.
Jennipher: SINCE WE'VE BEEN
HERE, WE HAVEN'T HAD A LOT
OF TIME TO SIT DOWN AND BE,
LIKE, ALL RELAXED.
Kelle: COME ON, GIRLS.
Jennipher: BUT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A GOOD TIME TODAY.
Kelle: EVERYBODY, I DON'T
WANNA LEAVE WITHOUT ANYONE.
Norelle: TODAY WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A TOUR OF NEW YORK CITY.
Kelle: ROCKEFELLER CENTER,
THAT'S WHERE THEY DO
ICE SKATING.
Norelle: AND KELLE IS
OUR TOUR GUIDE.
Kelle: THIS IS CHRISTIE'S.
YOU GUYS, THIS IS WHERE I SPEND
MOST OF MY TIME WORKING
AT AUCTION HOUSES.
I WOULD LIKE EVERYONE TO KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT ME, AND I'LL
KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT THEM.
I FIGURED I'D SHOW YOU
THE 5th AVENUE STORES.
GUCCI, MY BABY.
Eva: ARE YOU THE ONLY CHILD?
YEAH, CLEARLY.
Kelle: WHAT DO YOU MEAN,
"CLEARLY"?
Eva: CLEARLY AN ONLY CHILD.
CLEARLY.
Kelle: IN MY HOUSE, LIKE,
I HAVE MY OWN FLOOR.
Norelle: REALLY?
Kelle: THE TOP FLOOR.
Toccara: MY DESCRIPTION
OF KELLE WOULD BE A PREPPY,
STUCK-UP, WHITE PERSON.
I LIVE ON THE COUCH.
I GOT THE LIVING ROOM.
I DON'T HAVE A FREAKIN' ROOM.
Jennipher: KELLE'S ON
EVERYBODY'S LIST RIGHT NOW.
Kelle: REMEMBER "NICK NEWS"?
Eva: UH-HUH.
Kelle: WHEN I WAS 11,
I DID A LITTLE THING.
Jennipher: SHE JUST TRIES
TO BE EVERYTHING.
AND THE GIRLS AREN'T GONNA
DEAL WITH THAT.
Kelle: THIS IS KELLE
SIGNING OUT ON MY BACKYARD.
Kristi: GUYS, WE HAVE
A NEW TOY.
Kelle: IT'S THIS T-MOBILE
SIDEKICK 2-WAY PAGER.
Norelle: INTERNET, E-MAIL,
A MOBILE PHONE...
IT'S LIKE A PHONE WITH INTERNET.
(Sidekick rings)
Kelle: WE'VE GOT A MESSAGE,
GUYS.
Women: WHOO!
Kelle: OKAY, "YOU'RE HAVING
A SPECIAL DINNER TONIGHT
AT YOUR NEW HOME.
BE READY BY 8:30.
DON'T BE LATE."
Eva: SO EVERYBODY'S ALL
EXCITED.
Amanda: WE HAD NO IDEA WHERE
OR WHAT OUR DINNER WAS GONNA BE.
Kelle: EVERYONE'S, LIKE,
RUSHING TO GET SHOWERED
AND GET DRESSED.
Tyra: HELLO.
Ann: I'M LIKE, "OKAY,
TYRA BANKS JUST WALKED
IN THE DOOR."
Toccara: AAH!
Yaya: AAH!
Toccara: I WAS LIKE, "AAH!
LET'S GO HAVE DINNER."
Tyra: I BOUGHT YOU SOME FOOD.
Amanda: DINNER WITH TYRA
IN OUR FAIRY TALE LOFT
IS JUST INSANE.
Tyra: YOU GUYS ARE EXTREMELY
SPECIAL.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THIS ROOM
HAS SOMETHING THAT'S NOT SAFE.
THAT IS INTERESTING.
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE WORKING WITH
SOME OF THE MOST AMAZING
FASHION PEOPLE WHICH YOU ALREADY
DID IN JAMAICA, RIGHT?
Eva: YES.
Tyra: HOW WAS JAMAICA?
Women: (chattering)
Cassie: EXCEPT FOR THE FACT
THAT JAY SAID WE DIDN'T
DO VERY GOOD.
Women: YEAH.
Tyra: EVERYBODY'S GONNA GET
FEEDBACK. LISTEN TO THAT.
AND REALLY EXAMINE YOUR BODY,
YOU KNOW, AND FIND OUT,
"OKAY, THIS IS NOT SO STRONG.
HOW CAN I MAKE THE WORLD THINK
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL?"
'CAUSE I HAVE A WHOLE LOTTA
STUFF.
YOU KNOW, I HAVE CELLULITE.
NOBODY WOULD EVER KNOW THAT,
YOU KNOW? 'CAUSE I COVER IT UP
IN A WAY THAT YOU'D NEVER KNOW.
I'LL TALK ABOUT IT,
BUT YOU'LL NEVER SEE IT.
IT IS YOUR JOB TO MAKE
THE PUBLIC THINK THAT YOU ARE
PERFECT.
BUT YOU ARE NOT.
NONE OF US ARE.
WHY DON'T WE GO AROUND THE ROOM
AND TALK ABOUT
OUR IMPERFECTIONS?
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOURS IS?
Ann: MY NOSE.
Tyra: A BUMP ON YOUR NOSE?
Ann: YEAH, I HAVE A BUMP.
Tyra: SOMETIMES AS A MODEL
YOU MIGHT GET MADE FUN
OF SOMETHING CONSTANTLY.
LIKE, "OH, LOOK AT YOUR BUMP
ON YOUR NOSE, ANN.
THE HUMPBACK NOSE..."
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
AND THEN YOU GET
TO A PHOTOGRAPHER OR SOMEBODY
LIKE J., AND HE'S, LIKE,
"THAT'S BEAUTIFUL."
AND YOU'RE LIKE, "HUH?"
Yaya: I HAVEN'T HAD CLEAR
SKIN SINCE... I DON'T KNOW WHEN.
Jennipher: I THINK IT'S
MY BIG BOOTY.
Tyra: BIG'S NOT ALWAYS BAD.
I GOT A BIG BOOTY, TOO, NOW.
Jennipher: I KNOW.
Toccara: MY THIGHS RUB
TOGETHER, AND WHEN I WENT IN
THE PANEL TO SEE YOU,
THEY GOT STUCK.
Leah: I THINK I SOMETIMES
CAN HAVE A COMMON LOOK.
Tyra: I THINK YOUR FOREHEAD
SAVES YOU.
Leah: I WAS ALWAYS MADE
FUN OF FOR THAT.
Tyra: YOU KNOW, WHEN I WAS
IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL,
IT WAS ALWAYS "FIVE-HEAD."
"YOU DON'T HAVE A FOREHEAD,
YOU HAVE A FIVE-HEAD.
IT'S SO BIG."
BUT THE FIRST THING THAT
THE MODELING AGENCY
THAT ACCEPTED ME SAID IS,
"YOUR FOREHEAD IS GOING TO BE
WHAT GETS YOU OVER,"
THAT IF I HAD A SMALLER
FOREHEAD, I WOULD'VE PROBABLY
LOOKED A LITTLE BIT TOO COMMON
AND TOO SAFE.
NORELLE?
Norelle: MY EARS.
I HATE THEM!
Tyra: NOW LET ME SEE 'EM?
Norelle: WHOO!
Kelle: MY PROFILE--
IT'S LIKE I HAVE A
PROTRUDING MOUTH.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I ALWAYS FEEL LIKE, IT'S LIKE,
A MONKEY MOUTH.
(record needle scratches)
Toccara: LIKE, OH, MY GOD.
DID SHE JUST SAY THAT?
Kelle: THE FIRST THAT CAME
TO MIND WAS A MONKEY, YOU KNOW?
AND IT'S, LIKE, WHATEVER.
GUESS I CAN LOOK, LIKE, REALLY,
I DON'T KNOW, PRIMITIVE.
Yaya: I WAS LIKE, "WHAT?!"
LIKE, "ARE YOU SERIOUS?"
YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE ISSUES,
BUT WHATEVER.
Tyra: WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO
SOME PROFILE SHOTS AND THEN
ANALYZE THAT.
OH, I MIGHT LIKE
YOUR MONKEY MOUTH, GIRL.
I'D BE LIKE,
"GO, CURIOUS GEORGE.
WORK IT OUT."
I'M GLAD YOU GUYS ARE SO HONEST.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
IT'S GREAT THAT EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS THAT YOU'RE
NOT PERFECT
AND THAT THIS IS A BUSINESS
OF SMOKE AND MIRRORS,
AND FOOLING PEOPLE TO THINK
YOU LOOK LIKE SOMETHING ELSE.
ALL RIGHT, I'M OUT.
Women: THANK YOU!
Tyra: BYE, GIRLS.
Cassie: TYRA WAS VERY
HELPFUL, AND IT WAS JUST SO COOL
BECAUSE SHE, YOU KNOW,
SHE'S ON OUR LEVEL.
Tyra: BYE!
Yaya: KELLE IS REALLY GETTING
ON MY NERVES NOW.
Toccara: DID YOU SEE WHEN SHE
WAS LIKE, UM, "DOES THE SIDE
OF MY MOUTH LOOK LIKE A MONKEY?"
Kelle: MY PROFILE--I ALMOST
FEEL LIKE IT'S LIKE,
A MONKEY MOUTH.
Yaya: IT'S ONE THING TO SAY,
(imitating Kelle) "OH, I'M
A WHITE GIRL WITH A TAN,
AND I'M LIKE TOTALLY..."
(normal voice) BUT THEN TO GO
AROUND CALLING YOURSELF
A MONKEY?
THAT'S JUST STUPID.
Jennipher: SHE'S LIKE, "YEAH,
AND I HAVE MY OWN FLOOR
AND MY OWN BATHROOM."
AND WE'RE LIKE, "WHY DO YOU
THINK WE THINK THAT YOU'RE
A SPOILED LITTLE BRAT?"
Toccara: A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE A LOT OF BAD THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT KELLE AND TALK ABOUT
KELLE BEHIND HER BACK.
I'M THE TYPE OF PERSON, I'M JUST
GONNA TELL YOU HOW I FEEL.
I WAS JUST TALKING TO YAYA
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN SAYING A LOT OF STUFF
ABOUT YOU.
Kelle: LIKE WHAT?
Toccara: YOU KNOW, LIKE,
THE COMMENTS YOU MADE, LIKE,
"MY MOUTH, IT LOOKS LIKE--
WHEN I'M FROM THE SIDE,
IT LOOKS LIKE A MONKEY."
Kelle: I DIDN'T THINK OF IT
LIKE THAT.
Toccara: I KNOW.
I UNDERSTAND, IT'S NOT YOU
TRYIN' TO BE WHITE,
OR THE PEOPLE THINK, YOU KNOW,
THE WAY YOU TALK.
WHAT IRKS A LOT OF PEOPLE
ABOUT YOU IS THAT YOU'RE
SPOILED.
Kelle: HOW AM I SPOILED?
I GET IT, I WAS GIVEN A LOT
OF THINGS, BUT A LOT THAT
I HAVE, I BOUGHT FOR MYSELF.
I WORKED HARD FOR IT,
AND I'M DAMN PROUD
OF EVERYTHING I HAVE.
I DON'T HAVE ANY FRIENDS HERE.
AND NO MATTER HOW I SAY THINGS,
I'LL JUST ALWAYS BE THE BAD GUY.
I TRY TO TALK TO PEOPLE,
AND I TRY AND BE FRIENDLY,
BUT EVERYONE OBVIOUSLY
GETS TOGETHER AND HAS--
CREATES THESE OWN LITTLE
OPINIONS ABOUT ME.
IT'S, LIKE, WHAT AM I SUPPOSED
TO DO?
IT JUST HURTS SO MUCH.
AND IT'S REALLY HARD.
I DIDN'T EXPECT IT
TO BE LIKE THIS.
Kelle: ALL THE GIRLS
BASICALLY GOT TOGETHER
AND STARTED TALKING ABOUT ME
AND SAW ME AS, LIKE,
THE SPOILED BRAT.
Amanda: IT'S REALLY EASY
FOR SOMEBODY TO PASS
A JUDGMENT ON SOMETHING
WITHOUT KNOWING ALL
THE INFORMATION.
Kelle: BUT I DIDN'T EVEN--
LIKE, PEOPLE ASK ME, "WHAT PAIR
OF PANTS ARE YOU WEARING?"
I'M, LIKE--
Amanda: OH, YEAH.
Kelle: "THEY'RE GUCCI."
I CAN'T HELP THAT.
IT'S ALL ME AGAINST EVERY--
BASICALLY, LIKE EVERYONE ELSE.
LOOK, I TRY TO BE, LIKE, STRONG
AND HARD SO THEY DON'T THINK
I'M WEAK AND CAN WALK
ALL OVER ME.
IT HURTS THAT YOU DON'T--
Amanda: COME HERE.
IT'S GONNA BE OKAY.
Kelle: KNOWING I HAVE, LIKE,
A FRIEND MAKES ME FEEL SO GOOD.
Jennipher: YOU GUYS!
TYRA MAIL!
TYRA MAIL! TYRA MAIL!
OKAY, "YOU HAVE YOUR FIRST
MEETING WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 12 OF YOU WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Ann: WHY ARE THEY DOING
THIS TO US?!
Kelle: I'M A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUS ABOUT TONIGHT'S
ELIMINATION JUST BECAUSE
I HAVEN'T SEEN PHOTOGRAPHS.
Jay: IT'S LOOKING
A LITTLE HOOTCHIE.
Kelle: EVERY GIRL
IS BEAUTIFUL.
BUT HOW YOU PHOTOGRAPH
CAN BE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
Leah: WHATEVER IT WAS
IN THAT LAST THING,
I WASN'T, LIKE, UNH.
Jay: DON'T MOVE THE HEAD
TOO MUCH.
DON'T LOSE YOUR POSE TOO MUCH.
Leah: LIKE, I'M REALLY,
REALLY NERVOUS ABOUT TONIGHT
WITH THE ELIMINATION.
I'M DEFINITELY A POSSIBILITY.
PINK POSITIVELY!
Ann: I'M SO NERVOUS.
MY PERFORMANCE IN JAMAICA
WASN'T UP TO PAR.
Jay: ENERGY!
Ann: SO IF I WAS ELIMINATED,
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED.
Tyra: HELLO, LADIES.
Women: HELLO.
Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGING PANEL
TO MAKE ITS FIRST CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER IN DETERMINING
WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A CONTRACT WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE WORLD--IMG.
THE WINNER WILL ALSO RECEIVE
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
SHOT BY FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
WHO'S ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT
OF MY EARLY MODELING SUCCESS.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
Women: (murmuring)
Tyra: NOW I'M GONNA INTRODUCE
OUR PANEL OF JUDGES--
MISS JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODELS.
Janice: THE FIRST SUPERMODEL.
Tyra: NIGEL BARKER, WHO IS
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
WE HAVE A NEW JUDGE--
NOLE MARIN.
NOLE IS A VERY PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND A STYLIST.
AND OF COURSE,
WE CAN'T FORGET...
Nolé: EMPRESS MINNIE,
THE LEGENDARY GIRL HERSELF.
(laughter)
Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
YAYA, YOU'RE FIRST.
YOU WENT TO JAMAICA,
AND WE HAVE YOUR BEST PHOTO.
HERE IT IS.
Janice: YA-YA!
YA-YA!
Nolé: STRONG.
Yaya: THAT'S SO HOT.
Nolé: EXTREMELY REGAL.
VERY STRONG.
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER
HAD ONE COMMENT, THOUGH.
HE SAID THAT YOU DID HAVE
A POOR COMPLEXION,
AND THAT YOU NEEDED TO WORK
ON THAT.
NEXT IS ANN.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: OKAY.
Janice: YOUR FACE--FLAWLESS,
BUT THE PASSION BEHIND IT--
ZERO.
Nigel: YOU'VE LOST THE HEELS
BECAUSE YOU'VE BURIED THEM
IN THE VOLCANIC--
IT WOULD BE NICE IF WE COULD SEE
A BIT OF THEM.
IT WOULD ACTUALLY GIVE YOUR LEGS
SOME MORE SHAPE.
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER
THOUGHT YOU WERE SO BEAUTIFUL,
BUT THEN HE SAID HE GOT YOU
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
AND OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS,
YOU WERE THE WORST.
Ann: OKAY.
Nolé: GIVE US THE PASSION,
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY,
SOMEONE WHO MAY NOT BE
AS PRETTY AS YOU
WILL CONQUER YOU.
Ann: ALL RIGHT.
Tyra: CASSIE.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
I LIKE HOW HER SHOULDERS
ARE KINDA UP A LITTLE BIT.
IT'S KINDA GIVING A LITTLE...
MM.
Janice: YOU LOOK ABOUT
TWO MONTHS PREGNANT THERE.
Tyra: YOU'RE A SLIM GIRL.
IT'S JUST YOU GET RELAXED
IN PUSHING YOUR BUTT OUT,
BUT YOU HAVE TO SUCK
YOUR STOMACH IN AT THE SAME
TIME.
AND IT'S REALLY HARD.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
LOSE WEIGHT OR ANYTHING, OKAY?
Cassie: OKAY.
Tyra: KELLE.
Janice: WHAT ARE WE
MODELING HERE?
Nolé: IT DOESN'T
SHOW ANYTHING.
Janice: THERE'S NO
BATHING SUIT.
Kelle: I KNOW.
Janice: THE HAND
COMING THROUGH YOUR LEGS
LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING
THAT IS ON A MAN.
(laughter)
Tyra: I SAW THE FILM,
AND YOU WERE VERY... MM. MM.
AND IT WAS LIKE, "WHO IS THAT?"
NORELLE.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: I DON'T GET IT.
YOUR SHOULDERS HERE
ARE THRUSTED FORWARD.
YOUR LEFT LEG IS LOST.
YOU DON'T SEE ANYTHING
OF THE BATHING SUIT.
THE RIGHT LEG LOOKS TORQUED.
Nigel: I JUST THINK
YOU NEED TO RELAX YOUR FACE.
YOU LOOK VERY UPTIGHT.
Tyra: A LOT OF YOUR PICTURES
DID HAVE THAT KIND OF TIGHTNESS,
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF YOUR BRACES.
LIP IS BEING PULLED DOWN.
OKAY, NEXT WE HAVE EVA.
IT IS A LITTLE MUSIC VIDEOISH.
YOU'RE PUTTING TOO MUCH WEIGHT
ON YOUR LEFT KNEE.
SO IT'S BECOMING LIKE, "HEY!"
AS OPPOSED TO...
Janice: OPEN UP "ELLE"
AND "VOGUE."
TRY TO COPY OR MIMIC
WHAT THE GIRLS ARE DOIN',
LIKE...
Tyra: JENNIPHER.
Nigel: IT'S ONE OF
THE BEST PICTURES
WE'VE SEEN SO FAR.
YOU SHOW A LOT OF CONFIDENCE.
AND YOU HAVE VERY LONG HAIR,
I NOTICE.
IS THAT ALL REAL?
YEAH.
Nigel: BEAUTIFUL,
BUT NOT VERY PRACTICAL
FOR MODELING.
Nolé: THE CRYSTAL GAYLE LOOK
IS NOT IN FASHION.
Tyra: AMANDA.
Nolé: OVERALL, YOU KNOW,
I THINK THAT YOU NEED
TO LOOK MORE LIKE A MODEL.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE GONNA SING
ON A PIANO.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: YOUR LEGS
ARE TOTALLY DISTORTED.
Tyra: GO TO THE CLOSE-UP.
Janice: GORGEOUS.
Tyra: YEAH.
Janice: GORGEOUS HEADSHOT,
BODY SHOT...
Tyra: YOU CONTINUE
TO RAISE YOUR EYEBROW.
YOU KNOW, THE "ZOOLANDER."
(laughter)
Janice: I USED TO BE ABLE
TO DO IT, BUT I HAVE
SO MUCH BOTOX IN MY FACE
THAT I CAN'T REALLY DO IT
ANYMORE.
Nigel: JUST ONE EXPRESSION.
Tyra: JULIE.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: OOH, I LIKE THAT.
Janice: FABULOUS POSE.
Julie: I FEEL LIKE I'M
ABOUT TO DO, LIKE,
THE LITTLE PIGEON THING,
WHERE I'M...
(imitates pigeon cooing)
(laughing)
Tyra: NICOLE.
Nigel: WELL, THE FACE LOOKS
VERY PRETTY.
Tyra: GIRL, WHEN I WENT
THROUGH YOUR FILM,
EVERY PICTURE WAS A PINKIE.
OH, MY GOSH.
WHEN I FIRST STARTED MODELING,
MY INTENSITY WAS IN MY LIPS.
I COULDN'T GET IT OUT.
Janice: WHAT'D YOU DO?
WHAT'D YOU DO?
(laughter)
Tyra: TOCCARA.
Toccara: HELLO.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nigel: IT'S A GOOD SHOT
OF YOU.
Toccara: OOH, I LIKE THAT.
Nolé: YOU REALLY HAVE
EMBRACED YOUR BODY.
Janice: OH, I DON'T KNOW.
YOU MIGHT BE GIVING
THESE SKINNY LITTLE BITCHES
A RUN FOR THEIR MONEY.
Tyra: NEXT WE HAVE LEAH.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nigel: INTERESTING,
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
ONE OF THE THINGS
I'VE NOTICED ABOUT YOU
IS THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT ME,
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE
STARING AT ME.
IN THIS PICTURE, THEY'VE CHOSEN
THE ONE PICTURE WHERE YOUR EYES
ARE NOT LOOKING AT THE CAMERA.
YOU HAVE MAD EYES.
Janice: THE POSE SUCKS.
Nolé: AND LOSE THE PEARLS.
Nigel: YES, LOSE THE PEARLS.
Nolé: (groans)
THIS IS A MODEL CONTEST,
NOT A SECRETARY CONTEST.
Tyra: TAKE OFF YOUR JACKET.
Janice: SCREW UP THE HAIR.
THERE. WE'RE GETTING THERE.
THERE YOU GO!
Nolé: THERE YOU GO.
Janice: NOW THAT'S A MODEL!
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID
THAT YOU ROLLED YOUR HEAD A LOT,
AND YOUR RHYTHM WAS OFF.
IT HAS TO BE ROLL, SNAP,
ROLL, SNAP.
AND YOU WERE SNAP, SNAP.
Leah: GOT IT.
Tyra: KRISTI.
Janice: IT'S GORGEOUS.
Nigel: I LIKE IT.
THE BODY LOOKS FANTASTIC.
Nolé: GREAT LEGS.
I'M ACTUALLY PRETTY IMPRESSED,
BUT LOOKING AT YOU HERE,
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU FELL OFF,
LIKE, THE DAIRY TRUCK.
Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME FOR
THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WE WILL CALL YOU BACK,
AND ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
THANK YOU.
Tyra: ANN.
Janice: THIS GIRL--NO.
SHE HAS NO DRIVE.
Nigel: I THINK SHE HAS
ONE OF THE BEST FACES HERE,
BUT MY BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH ANN
IS THAT SHE JUST HAS
NO PERSONALITY.
SHE HASN'T GOT ANY OOMPH.
Tyra: TOCCARA.
Nigel: SHE'S DEFINITELY
GONNA BREAK THE MOLD.
Janice: SHE'S GONNA BREAK
SOMETHING.
Nolé: SOMETHING.
Tyra: I THINK TOCCARA IS
BODACIOUS, BUBBLICIOUS, SEXY.
SHE HAS A FACE THAT IS STRONGER
THAN A LOT OF THE GIRLS.
Janice: THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S TRUE.
Tyra: NICOLE.
Janice: THERE'S SOMETHING
VERY MODEL TO ME IN NICOLE.
Nigel: SHE HAS
A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
Tyra: JULIE.
Nolé: I LOVE THAT JULIE
EMBRACES HER HERITAGE
OF BEING INDIAN.
Janice: JULIE DOESN'T KNOW
HOW TO GIVE THAT EXTRA SOMETHING
ALONG WITH THE POSE.
Tyra: AMANDA.
Nolé: THERE'S A MAJOR
QUESTION MARK WITH AMANDA.
Tyra: THE GREAT THING
ABOUT HER--SHE'S HAD A BABY.
Janice: SHE'S HAD A BABY?
Nolé: SHE HAD A BABY?
Tyra: SHE'S A MOM.
Nigel: WOW.
LOOK AT THAT STOMACH.
Nolé: GREAT BODY, THOUGH.
Tyra: YEAH, YOU CAN'T
EVEN TELL, SO...
Janice: BITCH.
Tyra: JENNIPHER.
SHE'S ONE OF THE GIRLS THAT
THINKS, YOU KNOW,
"MY HAIR IS LONG.
THAT MAKES ME PRETTY."
Janice: SHE'S NOT, LIKE, POW,
BUT SHE'S NOT--SHE'S NOT A DOG.
Tyra: EVA.
Nolé: GHETTO SUPERHERO
IN THAT PICTURE.
Tyra: THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
WHAT WOULD HER NAME BE?
Nolé: SHANIQUA.
Tyra: EVALICIA.
Nolé: EVALICIA.
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
Tyra: THERE YOU GO.
NORELLE.
Nigel: I DON'T KNOW.
NORELLE IS A MESS TO ME,
ESPECIALLY IN THIS PICTURE.
Nolé: THE WAY
SHE PRESENTED HERSELF TONIGHT
WAS DEPLORABLE.
Tyra: SHE REMINDS ME OF
THE YOUNG GIRLS THAT COME
INTO THE MODELING AGENCIES
THAT ARE JUST REALLY AWKWARD
AND GAWKY.
Janice: YEAH, WITH THE BRACES
AND THE BITING OF THE LIP.
Tyra: KELLE.
Nolé: SHE'S COMPLETELY
A COUTURE DIVA.
Tyra: I THINK KELLE'S SKIN
IS, LIKE, FABULOUS.
IT--IT LOOKS LIKE A LOTION AD
TO ME.
CASSIE.
Janice: SHE'S GOT THAT WHITE
KIND OF,
SELL A LOT OF MASCARA THING.
Nolé: I'D LIKE TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO WITH CASSIE.
Tyra: LEAH.
Nigel: INTERESTING EYES,
BUT TOO FOCUSED, I THINK.
SORT OF POSSESSED.
BUT LOOK AT THE BODY.
BODY IS DYNAMITE.
SHE IS IN.
Janice: SHE'S NOT MEMORABLE
TO ME.
Tyra: I CALL HER
THE SOCCER MOM, YOU KNOW?
SHE'S LIKE, "HI, HONEY.
YOU READY TO GO TO SCHOOL?
DO YOU HAVE YOUR KNEE PADS?"
I WANNA SEE IF WE CAN
RISE TO THE CHALLENGE
OF BREAKING THE SOCCER MOM OUT
AND PUTTING EDGY IN HER.
YAYA.
Janice: THIS GIRL IS A DIVA.
Tyra: ABOUT 60%
OF HER PHOTOS WERE USABLE...
Janice: MM-HMM.
Tyra: WHICH IS
A VERY SUCCESSFUL
MODEL'S PERCENTAGE OF FILM
THAT SHOULD BE USED.
KRISTI.
Nolé: WHEN I SAW KRISTI
IN THE LINEUP,
I WAS JUST MORTIFIED, LIKE,
HOW POORLY SHE WAS DRESSED.
Janice: SHE LOOKS LIKE,
YOU KNOW, MODEL THERE,
BUT IN PERSON...
(imitates buzzer)
Tyra: WE'VE REACHED
A DECISION.
Tyra: I HAVE 13 YOUNG LADIES
STANDING BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE 12 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE 12 OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME I'M GONNA CALL...
IS YAYA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Yaya: THANK YOU.
Tyra: KRISTI.
JULIE.
JENNIPHER.
KELLE.
CASSIE.
TOCCARA.
CONGRATULATIONS, TOCCARA.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Toccara: THANK YOU.
Tyra: NICOLE.
EVA.
NORELLE.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
AMANDA.
Amanda: THANK YOU, JESUS.
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS,
AMANDA.
Tyra: WILL ANN AND LEAH
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
THERE ARE TWO OF YOU
THAT STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I HAVE ONLY ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
LEAH, AT YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
IT WAS REALLY VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THE PHOTOGRAPHER
TO CAPTURE YOU BECAUSE
YOUR RHYTHM WAS SO OFF.
ANN, AT YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU WERE SO DEAD.
A PHOTOGRAPHER NEEDS TO BE
INSPIRED.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
Tyra: ANN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Ann: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU'RE STILL IN THE
RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Ann: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANKS, LEAH.
Leah: I KNOW
I COULD'VE DONE BETTER.
THAT'S THE NAME OF THE GAME
THOUGH,
YOU HAVE TO GIVE IT ALL
AT THAT ONE MOMENT,
AND IF YOU DON'T,
THEN YOU DON'T GET THE JOB.
I DIDN'T GET THE JOB, YOU KNOW?
YOU DO GET TOLD "NO."
I GOT TOLD "NO," BUT THAT
DOES NOT MEAN I'M GONNA STOP.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT YOU'RE NOT GONNA SEE ME
OUT THERE.
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
Tyra: COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
THE GIRLS GET
DRAMATIC MAKEOVERS.
Man: YOU READY?
I'M GONNA CUT IT ALL OFF.
Toccara: WITH THE BLUE EYES
WITH THE BLOND--I DON'T KNOW.
THAT SOUNDS A LITTLE SCARY.
Amanda: THE GIRLS ARE
STARTING TO FEEL INTIMIDATED
BY ME.
>> Tyra: AND SOMEONE REVEALS
A SECRET THAT COULD GET
HER HOUSEMATE ELIMINATED.
Eva: THAT'S WHY I DON'T
CONFIDE IN ANYONE.
THAT'S WHY I DON'T TELL ANYONE
ANYTHING.
♪♪♪